me imagino que en algún momento has
estado expuesto un poco a la idea de lo
que es una función o en algún momento de
tu experiencia en cuanto a las
matemáticas pero lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es explicarlo un poco más
formal de lo que normalmente lo hago y
luego relacionarlo un poco con conceptos
de vectores y un tanto de álgebra lineal
que hemos visto hasta ahora
así que una función en realidad es
enrollar es la relación entre los
elementos de un conjunto con los
elementos de otro conjunto así que
digamos que tenemos un conjunto de xy
que por cada elemento de dicho conjunto
lo vamos a relacionar o asociar con un
elemento de otro conjunto nos
asociaremos con un elemento del conjunto
jr así que imagina que este es mi
conjunto x este que está por aquí sería
el conjunto x y luego por acá tendríamos
el conjunto en el que no necesariamente
debe ser más pequeño simplemente lo
dibujé así y la función es simplemente
tomar ciertos elementos de mi conjunto x
así que tomemos o visualicemos que este
punto de aquí corresponde
este conjunto y la función dirás ok me
dije me diste un elemento de xy ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es darte un elemento
de asociado con dado término de x
entonces se verá de esta forma usted
vamos a asociar nuestro elemento de x
con el elemento de y por lo cual vamos a
decir que lo estamos mapeando y lo que
realmente significa es que estamos
relacionando lo o asociándolo con un
miembro de iu y luego si me das otro
punto por aquí lo voy a relacionar con
otro punto del conjunto y podríamos
incluso relacionarlo con el mismo punto
que utilizamos primero en el conjunto
jet y esta es la anotación solamente nos
está diciendo que estamos mapeando de un
conjunto x y es de lo que estamos
hablando en términos generales a lo del
conjunto y probablemente podría decir mg
y esto está haciendo demasiado abstracto
para poder interpretar funciones vistas
anteriormente entonces bien déjame solo
escribo debajo una función que
probablemente has visto mucho en
ocasiones anteriores
vamos a decir que tenemos f x x cuadrada
entonces como podríamos escribirla en
esta anotación
bien pues ésta es una función asumiendo
que ésta es un tanto relacionado con
ella entonces vamos a escribirlo como
que f va a ir
si te das cuenta en nuestra función f x
igual a equis cuadrada puede tomar
valores en todos los reales o también
podríamos definirla como para los
números enteros pero en esta ocasión
vamos a decidir que esta función
f va a ir de los reales y va a mapear
por así decirlo o va a ir hacia los
números reales también simplemente lo
que estamos diciendo es que podemos
poner cualquier número real aquí y vamos
a caer en los reales otra vez entonces
en este caso si x es un número real va a
ir al mismo conjunto pero va a ser un
número legítimo pues lo que está
haciendo nuestra función es esto así que
si estamos en los números reales
obviamente caeremos en los reales pero
siempre y cuando tomamos un punto en r
lo maté amos en otro punto en r entonces
es lo que estamos haciendo tomamos un
punto y lo asociamos con la función x
cuadrada y ahora lo que quiero hacer es
una sub notación o al menos no dejarlo
como solamente en la mente pues es la
primera vez que estoy tratando de
exponer acerca de funciones con este
tipo de notación entonces estaba
pensando que dieras tu número pienses en
un número real equis y lo lees al
cuadrado entonces simplemente lo que
pasa es que estamos cambiando este
número al elevarlo al cuadrado y
entonces vuelve a caer en los reales
vamos de equis a equis cuadrada y de
hecho esta es otra forma de notación
pero estamos escribiendo la misma cosa
estos dos enunciados de por aquí este
primero y este segundo son idénticos
solamente que creo que no es muy común
ver esta segunda anotación sin embargo a
mí me gusta porque siento que nos
muestra de mejor manera el mapeo o la
asociación que estamos teniendo de un
conjunto con otro entonces es una
especie de poner x
en una pequeña máquina y tornarla o
transformarla en x cuadrado y eso es lo
que está realizando nuestra función
entonces para mí esa notación implica
una mejor forma de representar el mapeo
entonces me das unas x las voy a asociar
con otro número real llamado x cuadrada
por lo que este va a ser otro punto y
esto es simplemente la terminología que
estoy utilizando y creo que este tipo de
cosas lo has visto anteriormente pero de
diferente forma y el conjunto del cual
estás mapeando se les llama dominio del
cual estamos partiendo se le llama
dominio que es justo lo que había
escrito en color rosa por aquí abajo y
bien ahora a la parte que estamos
mapeando estamos asociando de un
conjunto a otro es conocido como el co
dominio así es su dominio y puede ser
normal que surja una pregunta en tu
cabeza y me digas oye pero cuando yo
tomé mi curso de álgebra o donde sea que
tú hayas aprendido funciones es muy
probable que te hayan dicho que es
aislado se llamaba rango sin embargo te
voy a explicar la diferencia entre estos
de hecho creo que yo lo aprendí cuando
tomé mi curso de álgebra 2 sin embargo
yo también lo conocía como el rango pero
bueno qué es lo que relaciona al
condominio con el rango pues es una sub
notación el co dominio es el conjunto al
que llegamos o estamos mapeando por así
decirlo por ejemplo aquí este es el
condominio y en nuestro ejemplo tenemos
los reales que son el dominio y el
condominio también son los reales
entonces la pregunta es como el
condominio se relaciona con esto y bien
el condominio es el conjunto que puede
ser al que posiblemente se llegue no
necesariamente todos los elementos o
puntos de condominio van a estar
relacionados con otros del dominio más
bien quiero decir que generalmente cada
elemento del conjunto x está asignado a
un único elemento del segundo conjunto
ahora el rango es un subconjunto del
condominio de hecho pueden ser el mismo
para cuando él
el elemento que parte de nuestro dominio
cae tanto en el condominio y respeta a
la parte del rango más adelante les daré
un ejemplo de esto para que quede más
claro pero entonces la definición de
rango sería el subconjunto del
condominio donde la función está
asociando un elemento pero bueno pasemos
al ejemplo para entender mejor entonces
digamos que vamos a definir la siguiente
función g la cual va ir de los reales va
a ir de mejor va a ir de r2
a ver a los reales entonces
esencialmente estoy tomando elementos de
r2 que van a ir así que vamos a ver de
qué forma diferente podemos ver esto y
ahora voy a tomar a los valores que
corresponden ser de r2 que podrían ser
como coordenadas así que tenemos que g
de dichos valores que sería x1 coma x2 y
vamos a decir que es igual a 2 entonces
está asociando asignando de r2 a r pero
esto siempre van a ser igual a 2 siempre
los elementos de r2 dijimos que van a
valer 2 entonces ahora déjame escribir
la otra anotación que probablemente no
la hayas visto antes pero a mí me gusta
porque hace la asociación la asignación
un poco más clara entonces g que va de x
coma x 1 x 2 a 2 entonces esta esta
parte de aquí la podríamos llamar como
regla de correspondencia que es lo que
parte de nuestra función a otra entonces
ahora la pregunta va a ser cuál sería el
dominio en
esta función pero aquí no la está dando
por definición sabemos que la parte de
arriba de r2 parte de r2 entonces ya
está dada nuestra definición y también
nuestro codo mío ya está dado por la
definición pues sabemos que vamos de r2
a r entonces dicho condominio va a ser
igual a r que estoy subrayando por aquí
entonces hasta el momento estos dos plus
en un tanto sencillos de ver pero ahora
viene lo interesante cuál es el rango de
mi función el rango sería el conjunto de
valores que la función de hecho está
asociando que en nuestro ejemplo siempre
llegamos o estamos asociando el valor 2
entonces el rango es el número o el
valor 2 y si queremos visualizar esto
pues bien podemos dibujarlo y sería de
la siguiente forma dentro de mi dibujo
tendríamos
que r2 vendría haciendo este espacio de
por aquí solo por por lograr visualizar
y r lo podemos representar por una
simple línea que nos marque los reales
entonces ésta representaría r que sería
la línea de puros números reales y lo
que nuestra función nos está diciendo es
lo siguiente es que tomamos un valor de
r 2 una coordenada de r 2 y siempre
caeremos en este punto de aquí en los
reales que es igual a 2 entonces se
vería de la siguiente forma digamos que
tenemos una coordenada aquí en nuestro
espacio de r2 digamos que esta sea la
coordenada 3 menos 5 y que dicha
coordenada va a ir a caer al valor 2 en
nuestros reales y esto es lo que nuestra
función g siempre hace así que mi
función g su co dominio es todos los
reales pero el rango es sólo el valor 2
ahora si escribo otro ejemplo digamos
que tenemos lo siguiente para que se
pueda ver un poquito más explicado que
no siempre va a ser simplemente un valor
que nosotros denominamos entonces
que tenemos la siguiente función h que
va a ir de rdr 2 que verde r2 y r3 aquí
debemos de ser muy cuidadosos porque
estamos yendo de una dimensión más
pequeña a una dimensión más grande vamos
de r2 y r3 entonces ahora escribir lo
siguiente digamos que h de r2 bueno de
nuestros valores x1 y x2 son iguales van
a ser iguales a las siguientes entradas
de mi coordenadas o de mi componente que
forma parte de r3 que vendría siendo x1
+ x2 así yo lo estoy denominando x2
menos x1 y nuestra tercera entrada de r3
sería igual al producto de x2 con x hola
ahora las preguntas son cuál es mi
dominio cuál es mi dominio y cuál es mi
rango y bueno pues mi dominio por
definición de mi función sería r 2 único
dominio también por la definición de
nuestra función sería r t
y de hecho voy de un espacio de dos
dimensiones a un espacio de tres
dimensiones entonces podemos siempre
asociar algún punto x1 y x2 a un punto
que esté en r3 y bueno de hecho no son
puntos son elementos de diferentes
dimensiones y bueno ahora una truculenta
pregunta interesante va a ser cuál es el
rango pues podemos siempre asociar todos
los puntos aunque quizás ese no sea el
ejemplo más sencillo pero nos va a
servir para comprender bastante bien
entonces donde es mikko dominio sr3 y mi
dominio es r 2 entonces siempre vamos a
tener que encontrar los puntos mediante
h que vayan de r2 r3 entonces mi rango
como puedes ver no es como cada
coordenada pero la podemos expresar de
la siguiente forma entonces déjame te
doy un ejemplo numérico para que veamos
cómo hay elementos que sí pertenecen al
rango que sí pertenecen más bien alto
dominio pero no pertenecen al rango
entonces digamos que tenemos h bueno voy
a utilizar mi notación
y ahora que estoy acostumbrada para
hacértelo ver un poquito más sencillo
entonces tomamos un elemento de r2 que
es una coordenada en este caso sea 23 h
que va de 23 a que es la regla de
correspondencia que tenemos abajo como
lo nombramos acá entonces sería 2 + 3
sería la primera entrada 5 luego la
diferencia nos va a dar uno que sea tres
menos dos es uno y nuestra última
entrada es el producto de los dos
números entonces tendríamos seis y aquí
ya vemos que este elemento pertenece a
nuestro rango nos pertenece a nuestro
rango y también por ende está en el
condominio
sin embargo veamos que tenemos aquí la
coordenada 2,3 que va a caer en un punto
que digamos que estaba por acá en r3 lo
voy a pintar de otro color
y 516 y es un elemento de r3 pero ahora
qué pasaría con lo siguiente es una
pregunta que yo te quiero hacer qué
pasaría si tengo un punto en r3 lo voy a
representar con diferente color digamos
que tenemos este punto y que sea el
punto 5 1,5 punto 10 finalmente es un
elemento de r3 entonces aquí mi pregunta
es este punto es un elemento del rango
definitivamente queda claro que es un
elemento del condominio pues está en r3
entonces definitivamente estará ahí pero
lo interesante es que pasa con el rango
bueno pues si tomamos esta primera
entrada como la suma de dos números pues
es un tanto razonable que es 5 si
tomáramos el 2 3 otra vez 2 a 5 la
diferencia nos vuelve a dar sin embargo
el producto de esos números no nos dan 0
por lo tanto no pertenece a nuestro
rango no es un elemento del
entonces creo que aquí se queda muy
claro que podemos ver que el rango va a
ser un subconjunto de todos estos puntos
en r3 que cumplan con nuestras
condiciones de nuestra regla de
correspondencia
ahora quiero introducirte a una pieza
más de todas estas terminologías con
respecto a las funciones viene esta
función de aquí vemos que va de r2 a ere
y otra función más común y yo creo que
las más usadas en nuestra experiencia
matemática es esta que tenemos por acá
que va de los reales a los reales vemos
que es como ir de un espacio
unidimensional al espacio unidimensional
y ella es muy conocida o es llamada como
una función de valores escalares o
valores reales valores y escalares o
valores reales como tú quieras pensarla
y hasta ahora cuáles de las funciones
como la más accesible o la más
entendible que hemos visto hasta ahorita
bueno alrededor de tu experiencia en
matemática si alguna vez has llevado
algo de cálculo
y podemos identificar la siguiente
función de esta forma vemos que esta
función va de r2 y r3 entonces esta es
una función con valores con valores
vectoriales aquí ya podríamos decir que
es como si tuviéramos una función que va
de rn donde n es mayor que 1 osea estará
siendo de r2 r3 y r4 o hasta de resident
entonces tú estarás tratando con una
función vectorial de valores vectoriales
por lo que esta función que definir por
aquí h es una función de valores
vectoriales bueno de cualquier forma
espero que todo lo que hemos aprendido
aquí de terminologías y notación de
funciones te sea realmente útil